citizens of the reject Nation hello my
name's Aaron who we have here we got
Andrew here Havey Aaron we got one
Andrew Gordon here we're here to watch A
Million Ways to Die in the West that's
why I'm talking here in this old uh
accent as they like to say I've never
seen this movie but I know I know it's
about uh one Mr Seth Rogan nope Seth
marar that's the guy he knows the stuff
about the movies you guys leave a
comment about this dang movie if you
like it if you seen it we're going to go
and embark on this whole dang thing like
subscribe hit that notification Bell
because Tara isn't here she is healing
up so send your comments down below
because we miss her we love her and we
will see her return to sing that Bell
song as she does so well ring that
[Music]
bell ring the bell full life reactions
over on the patreon where you sync up
with your own dang copy so you can watch
it with us Us in real time like we're
old buddies like we're old Pals guys
John and Greg covers several things
exclusively over there a lot of movies a
lot of shows you're going to love it
you're going to have a great old time
all right you ready to watch million
days Dy in the west let's do it all
right then
[Applause]
Yeehaw Andrew you're a connoisseur in
westerns have you seen a lot of them uh
not too many the but I would say my
favorite Western is Back to the Future
Part three how about you D Jango and
janed I I have not not seen Jango I've
not seen very many Quinton Tarantino
films at
[Music]
all we're already getting that Western
feel I like it now wonder what's like
the line between being a genuine Western
and being a parody As we watch this well
I mean I've only seen Ted and I've
watched Family Guy but obviously Seth
McFarland loves runchy comedy so he also
loves his comedy cutaways a staple of
that
man ah we got a couple returning cast
members from Ted Patrick Harris
okay Sarah Silverman surprisingly
doesn't seem like an odd choice to be in
this movie but Liam n I'm shocked West
stud oh wow who's that uh well he was
sagot and Street Fighter I if you saw
that he was also in uh Last of the
Mohicans uh he seen so many different
movies
I understand this is an homage to how
movies used to do it back in the day but
I'm happy they don't do this anymore
could you imagine sitting through
credits in the theater for like 6
minutes yeah some people are born into
the wrong time and place this was the
American frontier in 1882 a hard land
for hard folk food was scarce disease
was rampant and life was a daily
struggle for survival damn hell this was
Miss America in 1880
holy
[__] to build a home and a life in this
harsh unforgiving country required that
a man be bold and tough as iron The Men
Who were courageous and resilient were
The Men Who prospered but some men were
just big
giant surprised you showed up Stark yeah
well you said you'd kill my family and
burn my house down if I didn't so is
there anything at all that I can say to
get you to call this
off
you yellow Stark well that's a little
racist to our hardworking friends over
here from the Far East right
guys the fake stashes talk this out you
know we can find a calm rational
solution maybe we even laugh about it
one day you know I ain't in the mood to
laugh oh hey look this will make you
laugh look at our shadows looks like our
shadows are about to kiss each
other oh my God Charlie oh my God thank
you so this is so generous of
you look we're laughing right we're
laughing now what what were we even
fighting about I I can't remember can
you oh I'll pay you the money you lost
Just Give Me 2 days to sell off a few of
my sheep I don't have that cash I'm
coming after you what a relief for all
these people who came out here hoping
that we would find an amicable solution
to this huh somebody shoot
some point out that guy's an English
teacher at our
school oh my God just a little taste
just a little taste just a little taste
I like the balance between the serus and
the like the parody yeah no it's funny I
mean I tell him I'll pay him off we go
our separate ways and that's it but no
he shoots me in the
leg you should have fought
him I should have fought him she's like
yeah you really are the guy is one of
the best shots around I look like I have
Parkinson's next to him what is that
it's just another way God m mysteriously
shows that he loves us but look
look that Albert I'm breaking up with
you of course as I talk about Back to
the Future Part three why don't you just
tell me what the problem is and then
maybe I can fix it maybe if I were older
the timing would be right but people are
living to be 35 these days a girl
doesn't have to just go off and get
married right away I have to work on
myself oh my God you did not just say
that I have to work on myself Louise
that's the oldest line in the book you
realize that yep it's not you it's me
right I love you I'm sorry maybe when he
becomes as somebody she'll come
back yes come on come on someone's
getting to
Ean you don't you I do it's really
[Laughter]
terrific oh another Ted uh oh and Family
Guy yeah it's Lois I thought I'd take
her out for picnic it sounds like she's
just about done up there oh poor
guy all over my oh
Jesus you're okay with your girlfriends
15 different guys every day and getting
paid to do it oh my job sucks too that's
how we make a
living well I got off work early and I
thought we could go for a walk by the
stream oh oh yeah no no I had to give um
so wait to kiss me get get some
mouthwash don't I have the best
boyfriend Millie honestly I I have no
[__]
[Music]
idea there's nothing wrong with breath
Andrew that's a true sign of
love how didn't you even get up
there goats can climb right I don't know
about goats but not sheep yeah I don't
know about sheep hey guys guys we heard
about Louise I that's horrible do you
you want to sit down I'm good I'm going
to rest my
[__] just looking at these old
pictures of me and Louise this is from
the carnival M oh
yeah look like a happy Cup this is the
squirt why did they do that back then
have you ever smiled in a photograph no
have you oh God no no you looked like an
insane person but right that's what I'm
saying n dude keep that Stone Face up I
say that cuz I suck at smiling
so she was the one thing that made the
shootings and the diseases and the wild
animals and the Indians and the general
depressing awfulness about the West
beable I didn't realize how tall he was
yeah let's get
up that's the answer to everyone's
problems the age old tradition forget
your troubles let's kill our livers what
is there to live for on the frontier in
1882 the American West is a disgusting
awful dirty dangerous place look around
you everything out here that's not you
wants to kill you Outlaws angry drunk
people scorned workers hungry
animals you you can get killed just
going to the bathroom there rattlesnakes
all in the grass out there and and even
if I make it you know what can kill me
Coler up the black the
black even if you survive all those
things you know what else can kill you
theing
Doctor oh you need an ear nail a nail in
my ear that is modern medicine for you
do I have a fever of 102 oh you need a
donkey
kicking constipation cramps dyspepsia
liver disease kidney disease hemorrhoids
it's like the smartest guy ever in 1882
literally die from their own
farts that is our mayor he is dead he
has been lying there dead for 3 Days the
highest ranking official in our town has
been a dead guy oh look at that look at
that as if to illustrate my point bye
bye Mr Mayor bye have fun becoming
wolf I want to live in the American West
cess pool of Despair and all of it why
don't you shut up you shut
up ow I don't know maybe you should TR
to talk to Louise that's a great idea
yeah that's the jackpot still got it
okay there it is good idea so I didn't
mean
now oh cuz talking to your ex while
you're drunk is always a great
idea oh I'm excited to see him ride a
horse tr you're going to get exactly
what you want oh God here we
go surpris he didn't fall was taking a
lot of rehearsal for that bet she has
new man already probably yeah maybe it's
Neil Patrick
Harris maybe it's Liam n oh yeah could
be that
to hey hey Albert what the hell are you
doing Lise we need to talk Lise please
listen to me I love you okay I'm sure
you're right for somebody else just not
for me wait let me just touch
[Laughter]
you I heard you fart once and it
went it was a sharp one
Shar little Sharpie poop toot and I
heard I really did think she was going
to have a guy there but yeah same come
on boy hey
down we'll be taking that gold off you
howy folks how oh there he is what can I
do for you fellas we're riding through
to Sherman Creek we obliged you could
tell tell us the shortest route Willam n
hey I can help you with
that I got a map right here uh clearly
want your gold sir I I'd take Bill be
pass safer too less chance of Bandits
and such uh one more thing you might do
for us you show us the
gold I ain't got no gold I wish old
plugger and I done give it up we're
going on back into town you're heading
back to town in the middle of the day a
prospector only does that when he's
found gold to sell o going into town to
get I might just have a little bit of
gold here take
it pick up your gun well I'm not just
going to take your gold that'll be
stealing oh no bye-bye Mr
prospector H we sh on
three oh man one a
two wow he's a cheater H clinch you
didn't have to shoot him clinch no I
didn't have to sweetart he would have
given you the gold point is I had to ask
him twice you're a son of a [__] is
what you
were don't you ever say that to me in
front of my man man's wife will respect
him oh oh my God I love you I'm like the
luckiest girl ever in the
H very convincing was not expecting them
to be married
leis you take Anna and right East and
hole up here in the old
stump
a take that dog yet she going to pet
that dog she going to keep that dog that
does suck for that old
guy guess the lesson here is don't lie
to Liam n well look who's up at two in
the afternoon get your life taken we
literally just had a conversation about
waking up at 2: in the afternoon before
we started
shooting I'm going to use the out housee
if I die out there will you guys just do
me one favor I want you to switch
seats he going to say eras my search
history your Western search history yeah
Albert you look terrible oh wow there's
that conf thanks a lot how you doing
buddy I'll take it it's days of past at
this point oh I haven't seen you in town
in a week and a half oh okay there we go
I just feel like I need to stay here
with my parents they're not going to be
around much longer to give back all the
love and affection that I got growing up
right guys
ow I love him so
much you got to get out of this fun I
mean you haven't Shor your sheep in
[Music]
weeks Oh no you're going home every
night to your girlfriend who loves you
you're having sex with her uh no Ruth
and I have what damn everyone else gets
to do that with her but you right that's
wild no Ruth wants to wait till we get
married she a Christian and so am I
and boy they have an interesting
relation have you ever had with anyone
well there was some [__] with my uncle
but that was oh what no oh my God this
got dark really quickly I'll get out
I'll meet some people yeah thanks
okay came out of my P
yeah that should have made me laugh that
was dumb me personally I'm over fart
jokes um I Dumb and Dumber did it
perfectly and then yeah it's been done
to death after that Ed look
look oh no you're right you called it
hey NE Patrick Harris he's
irresistible she told me she didn't want
to see anybody she told me she had to
work on herself look at that Foy the
owner of the mustachery oh look at that
he's kissing her us men with mustaches
were
irresistible I can't afford it the
creams the waxes the lotions I don't
have the
money it's true it is expensive to have
a mustache oh hey look it's the ice and
itchy uhoh that's going to land on
somebody it's so neat I know it's
actually really interesting how they do
it is this one company out in Boston had
to get a bason reference in for Seth
mcfallen and ponds and they just
[Applause]
ship that went South so
fast
Jesus
oh jeez no more shall they nibble
wantedly at the teeth of our coffers I
we also like to offer a heartfelt prayer
to the family of James Addison I thought
I was going to land on somebody like
entirely not somebody's face yeah yeah
yeah James we will think of you lovingly
this July As We Sip the cold summer
beverages for which you gave your life
they're still going to use the
ice Lewis Barnes and his sister Anna
they've just moved here to old stump and
they planed to build a farm well that
concludes today's service so may God
bless you for another week and there is
a mountain line warning in effect oh wow
a mountain line warning in effect I'm
the mustachery
that's
awesome you love it there Andrew oh I I
would so go there I was thinking that we
could go dress shopping later I was
thinking you need a new dress something
expensive stupidly expensive yeah yeah
you think she's going to become jealous
when she sees chariss thone with Seth
what's up kiddo never seen you in here
before it's just browsing you don't have
a mustache though I might get one I said
I was thinking about growing one like
one of those ones that goes down along
the side of my
mouth the edge of my jaw and then
becomes my sideburns a Mobius mustache
mobus mustache that's the
one you should know that kind of
mustache is a very costly facial
accessory you're a sheep
farmer know your place stealing a guy's
girlfriend that's what you're doing you
feel good about that hey Louise dumped
you my friend it's not my fault she
wanted someone with more to offer
oo I can give her a lavish home warm
blankets wrapped candies and a mustache
you know you man yeah that's what she's
doing
oh damn he's got some good comebacks
he's smooth with it NPH don't miss even
in 1882 he NPH don't miss n pH don't
miss oh hey sweetie hi hi Mark hey Ed W
what a long day poor guy got to earn a
living what do you think about us
spending the night together but Eddie
we're Christians and I want to do the
correct thing in the eyes of the
Lord but if we really do love each other
don't you think God would be okay with
him you're talking about premarital
relations oh oh God damn
it
oopsy yuck
yeah that's going to leave a
mark I'm done I'm leaving I'm going to
San Francisco I don't know how I lasted
this long I hate the frontier I hate
everything in it well what am I going to
do I'm your best friend that's why I
want you to have these it's like w is
still a teddy bear Albert these are your
favorite socks yeah and I want you to
have
that you're gross Edward this is your
lucky
handkerchief not lucky
anymore well hello to you
[Laughter]
yeah oh God blow your own
horse hey watch it pal I think you owe
me a drink B you best watch where you
stand I'm thirsty why don't you go on
down the river and take a dunk could be
wrong but I believe this actor was in 8
Mile one of Eminem's
friends also never seen a m ah be a good
watch for you my yeah Curtis Hansen did
that
one oh wow definitely going to make it
tastier you going to kill you quicker
than I thought quicker than I imagined
woo hey
ah Albert hurry get in
position
damn
oh yeah we're both getting hurt pretty
badly
that's smart of them that's smart to
do this fight is way more violent than
yours looks like they're doing Rock them
sockum
oh I love how unfaced she
looks oh oh that was actually going to
hit him so sorry you I put a new move in
there you don't just put a new move in
you that's why we have the meeting
that's why we have the meetings it
wouldn't be a western without a bar
fight oh wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow love
[Music]
interest [__] come
on are you keeping count of all the ways
to die in the west have we had a million
yet I think we have we're close we had a
whole scene laying out all of them yeah
we've seen ice we've seen stabbings
farting stained handkerchiefs who this
this is plugger hey plugger that was
your brother in there huh yeah leis he's
always been a little rambunctious I'm
I'm uh Albert by the way Welcome to our
awesome Town thanks this is how you get
over someone Aaron that's how you get
over someone getting under someone we
were wanting a change so we came out to
the frontier looking to build a farm oh
that's what I do cattle uh no sheep well
that's got to be fulfilling work though
hey it's like being a dog walker for 150
really stupid
dogs oh
[__] Jesus what is that it's the mayor
it's the mayor oh so how did you guys
meet she moved to town a couple years
ago to take over the school marm job our
old school marm got her throat spped by
a fast moving tumble weed in front of
the kids oh yeah let me help
you we were together I just remember
thinking how can I possibly be this
happy she likes me now but one day she's
going to figure out that she's too good
for me it sounds like you've been over
backwards for this girl but what has she
giv you back I told you she allowed me
to be
happy allowed that's kind ofed up that
you would use that word you know that
right this Foy guy is that much of a
douche she'll figure it out if she's
smart solid advice sometimes a girl has
to get a few [__] out of her system
before she realizes what a good guy
looks
like
it's actually my first cigarette
ever definitely a
cigarette it looks like tobac
[Music]
rattlesnake oh diamond back just it's
okay just hold perfectly still and it'll
go away okay
okay now I'm nervous I'm not even in the
movie isn't the fair on Saturday Lise is
going to be there and she's going to be
with FY I'm going to put myself in
inauguration I'll go with you no better
way than make your ex go from what you
backck more than to let her see with
another girl exactly too bad she's going
to end up with Liam niss in the end
totally she's totally going to stay with
her husband and not leave him for Seth
McFarland you shot the pastor's son you
realize they're probably going to hang
you for this who gives up what they want
when clinch gets into town it's not
going to matter what they do why' you
guys split off oh he went to sell the
gold right would he do that in town
where they are there's going to be a man
who's faster than clinch and then clinch
is going to be the dead man and I'm
going to smoke a cigar to celebrate I
don't think clinch would like you
talking about him that way so what she's
saying is she's obsessively in love with
him let's see if he gets here before you
find yourself at the end of a rope who
was just thinking that what's the
timetable and when he's going to
probably get hung I feel like it's
usually a week I don't know that for a
fact I just think that's sounds like an
estimated good time I feel the pastor's
son they would maybe expedited but we
shall see oh no no no no no no no guys
no no no Andrew Jonathan no
Andrew
[Music]
yeah I've never seen it separated like
that in two words photo
photogaphs don't you freaking smile
looks like looks like a prison photo
like a mug shot supposedly there's some
guy in Texas who smiled one time while
he was getting his picture taken that we
were just talking about that last week
is that true no I mean I heard it
somewhere I don't know if it's true
everybody hold
still
holy [__] what the hell holy [__] that's
another
du that's another way to
die God this
Fair ladies and gentlemen step right up
step right up try a sample of Sir oh my
god do you recognize this
actor oh it looks so familiar Saved by
the Bell the principal that's right
Ogden's celebrated stomach bitters can I
just ask celebrated by who look at the
ingredients alcohol morphine oh I want
to try that so badly Mercury with I need
it science and
red red flannel there's shirt Red
Flannel pieces of
shirt it gives it a little kick right
Mak it feel like a lumberjack that's
them right uh uh quick Let's uh pretend
you just said something funny to oh my
God you are you
are
just introduce me I'm not going I'm not
going to introduce oh uh this is Anna
she's I'm his girlfriend she's my
girlfriend she's the new
GF new GF Big Time lot of sexual
activity I live inside her so if you
want to send me a letter you got to
address it care of her type of
relationship we all aspire to have I
have that skirt yep oh you do yeah I
wore it to the fair like two years ago
but good for you for trying to bring
bring it back well I figure only a
complete idiot would throw away a
perfectly good
thing we were going to go check out the
shooting gallery over there you guys
want to join what oh yes and let's make
things interesting a nickel a Target can
you afford that uh how about a penny
what's a matter Albert is business bad I
understood that joke I get
it good Lord Albert you're such a sheep
skate
oh
they're so dumb that they're actually
funny oh wow that seems
unnecessary what's wrong with like ducks
or oh my god
really okay there you go ma'am thank you
baby care to
try it's like yes I played at my local
7-Eleven I got this m
seems you owe me 6 cents wait hang on a
sec you want to make this
interesting if I can shoot six out of
six on Albert's behalf you owe him a
dollar ooh a dollar I've never seen a
dollar nobody's got a dollar let us see
the dollar oh that's one of the
producers a whole dollar Alex suus I
believe his name is the guy said I've
never seen a dollar how fast can this
thing go you can play double or triple
speeds but that's for the experts as
fast as you can
whoa oh my
God
damn
whoa no congratulations you're a winner
I just meant her skills I don't approve
I just meant the skills not the actual
game itself I don't
condone I just me how good she was there
it is it's beautiful
wow
Andrew just playing with you I know I
know a man whose girlfriend does his
shooting for him isn't that a fine how
do you
[Applause]
do how how is that funny why why is
what's funny about that how do you do is
a greeting why is that funny you why why
you laughing I don't know he was
laughing is you and McGregor ob one oh
wow what a funny he should have been
like hello there never been more serious
in my life you and me pistols you
wouldn't have a prayer kiddo tomorrow 8:
a.m. that duck is so goofy looking why
don't we say a week from today I got
sheap stuff I got to do tomorrow
anyway I honest I have no idea what just
happened I was I I was like out of my
body hbert did you see the look on
Louisa's face no why it's like he became
a man you had a fire in your belly for a
second there pal yeah I I don't have
that side to me I honestly don't know
what just happened you got her attention
I mean you might die in a week but you
got a retention I'm sick to my stomach
my stomach is you're worked up that's
what it is let's get a drink hey it's
our sweet young couple could I interest
you folks in some Wild Root cream
oil
Jesus
okay okay did you get jump scared too I
kind of saw it coming to be honest oh
really I've picked up on the fact that
every scene ends with a comedic bit I
haven't seen enough movies didn't know
that was coming it seems like yeah every
every almost every scene ends with
something funny happening or someone
dying or someone dying which was meant
to be funny hey why are you being so
nice to me you show up out of nowhere
you're this complete anomaly in my world
of terribleness out here I mean you must
have a million better things to do than
this a million I just don't know
anything about you well can I ask you
something about you yeah flip the tables
that's right why do you love
Louise we we did this already classy
she's fun she's insanely gorgeous hey no
look she's really pretty yes but I don't
see what else she's got going for her my
impression was that she was a little
sour and self-absorbed and like she is
so much cooler than her you act like
this girl was performing some kind of a
charitable act by dating you Albert
you're a
catch you've made something of yourself
out here you know a lot of people can't
say that you're a good sheep farmer I
suck at sheep stop cutting yourself down
there was a sheep in house last week
wandered in there and then when I went
to pick it up somehow it had made $20
[Laughter]
aim up sheep
boy oh there we go there all righty was
that someone else who shot it I just
realized there were Family Guy episodes
that did you know the Star Wars Episodes
so it was cool to see you and McGregor
there cuz he's Seth McFarland's such a
huge Star Wars fan
I love those Star Wars Family Guy
episodes so good I think I saw them like
once or a long time ago they're so funny
I know we have a dangerous job to do
here but I'm taking
[Music]
this yeah that works that's
right P 3D
it's going to hit him right in the face
yep
o oh Jesus just like he called out
earlier like the doctors with their
weird
methods oh nice this got to be
interesting for her cuz he's the exact
opposite of her husband a good honest
man okay getting a little bit better
it's getting better slowly but surely
[Music]
oh no his dad God Dam it over no more
friends all right make a fart dad you
have earned one of Anna Barn's very
special super super secret cookies wait
what is this I I do I was just thinking
that the last time somebody gave me one
of these I became convinced that prairie
dogs could read my mind just dig a
little bit you can get so messed up
doing that there you go
so there oh my God he's going to be so
baked oh
yeah he's freaking the hell out really
weird yep sure enough is it supposed to
be like this she's got such a high
tolerance for it though you gave me the
right amount right like you don't oh my
God he's paranoid he's like on a roller
coaster right now that's not
stopping it out see see bones are deep
today like there's a lot more I think my
body is patting up for the winter which
is weird because it's not winter but
there's a lot just a
[Laughter]
lot oh my God Anna he knows he knows he
knows what we're he knows what this is I
don't want to no I don't I don't want to
join I don't want to join that was a
sweet scene I like that one I like I
like call their scenes together I think
they're they have good chemistry yeah
and I like their interactions she's got
a way of just boosting his morale and
confidence I like it supper time you
lazy
oh fake sleeping damn
was TW a trap ooh
ooh who's lazy now Sheriff sorry dude
you were able to survive rush hour but
not this
movie wouldn't be a western without a
[Applause]
[Music]
dance she she is stunning I don't know
why he still got eyes for Lou cuz he
doesn't he cuz he vied himself so low he
doesn't imagine there's a possibility I
know well there we go wow I think he's
uh the tables are starting to turn oh
[__] I'm totally overdressed aren't I
and the lady at the boutique told me to
buy this and no one else is wearing this
who cares what these are allers but you
you I like your bustle by the way oh
yeah I really love that the most
alluring what and then I lifted up and
I'd be like a [__] it's a big joke I
know exactly cuz look when you lift it
up there's nothing but a metal cage
under there
wow well the very least this will be a
good way to spend my last night a li
right confidence do you trust
me yeah I do good you're going to be
fine wonder if she's going to help him
from somewhere thank you hey hey it's
great to be back here in old stump hey
any Indians here tonight oh
God that's an interesting C
okay they're giving me the lantern enjoy
the bison and I hope you're enjoying
your drinks as much as my horse enjoyed
making them for
you you men who long for love you may
not have the looks you may not have the
dash go in your
[Music]
foot but you need be a king to make any
maen of the name you may not have the
cash but you that girl your own you only
a mustache hey how sh out you're Wonder
to get in well here is my
advice get it you can have your you only
got getting his practicing get it in
[Music]
buddy
mustache
[__] you know what I would do if I
were Seth or Albert what would you do
shave his mustache in the middle of the
night M Pro
strats nice
oh smart going to get him so messed up
for the next day give him the poopies so
I guess it's kind of weird knowing that
a woman can out shoot you huh um if you
don't mind my girlfriend and I are
enjoying each other's company want to
know the real kicker though I can out
drink you too a man can't say no to a
challenge like that 50 cents to the
winner
3 [__] don't feel bad alcohol doesn't
harmonize well with a woman's frail
Constitution anyway I guess not yes
trick him by activating his ego put
fragility in defense mode you have the
nicest guy in the world throwing himself
at your feet and here you are with this
complete [__] who I go out with is my
own business why don't you mind your own
[__] o you so blind eyes that Big
D they're not that big mytic Chinese
like oh God I I like how that's all she
took from that conversation how big her
eyes are we'll keep us warm though are
you cold a little here no no no it's
okay no it's fine it's the manly thing
to do I just want to say thank you I
could
gotten this far without you and I think
I can do it h I still feel like I don't
know anything about you I feel like
every time I bring it up you change the
subject my story is a lot like yours I
suppose I hate the West just as much as
you do do you really oh I like you even
more
now there is something about connecting
over Mutual hatred that's just so much
deeper than mutual love it's true right
if two people hate the same things it
creates a bond it really does actually
hey Bridget Bridget yeah she knows what
is this this is just a little something
to say thank you okay don't get too
excited what is it what is it what is it
a picture oh it can't be a picture that
burns oh it is a picture the guy that
smiled oh was in Texas I think he's
smiling isn't that amazing I bought that
off a pedler it was coming through town
last week this is the guy I was telling
you about this guy would have had to sit
there and smile for 30 sustained seconds
I know I've never been happy for 30
seconds
no one has is that Richard Maul I can't
tell in the picture rest in peace if it
is voice of two fa and Batman the Animan
no one's ever done anything like this
for me oh come on now thank
you kiss kiss her kiss the girl a
million ways to kiss in the
west Feel the Moment
yeah sure Liam n's going to be be happy
about that I'm sorry I I shouldn't have
done that that was very genuine it's
fine you've just been a really good
friend to me that's all just a friend I
actually love these scenes where they're
a little more serious and a little more
on the Romantic side like those are
actually my favorite scenes same they're
yeah they're really I mean the comedy is
still like I'm enjoying most of the
comedy but yeah the comed's all
right but all the scenes with them are
awesome yeah oh this is my favorite part
of the movie these two good luck
tomorrow I'm going to be there good as
sweet as this is I bet it's going to end
with a bit H probably but what's the bit
it's going to undercut everything we've
just
done
yeah there is that the
[Music]
bit a genuine scene going to end
genuinely oh
no damn he saw it Oh I guess guess you
could say Liam n's eyes were there so he
technically was
there what the
hell it's Doc Brown he's working on an
invention electricity hello oh they have
electric I called it you're SI oh my God
I called that wow that was just a joke I
was saying
too hey experiment I swear I did not
know that was there I promise you guys I
did not know wow I didn't know either
swear on everything that's awesome I
swear on I swear and everything I was
just saying that as a joke that's crazy
but it did end with a joke we did call
it I promise that was just that was a
great joke that was awesome he always
smells like sheep but he doesn't deserve
to be shot Louise my decision is final
now do it I I'm really TI Louise oh my
god really telling her to do what I
think he's
yeah my social sture is
significant
uhoh what she gave him I had the
rungs he'll be able to show up but he
might have to go to the restroom a bunch
gives uh our boy the upper hand cuz he
got the
poopies D of course of course
I think he's in the
bathroom she got messed up oh well
now I didn't think you'd show sheepy
yeah listen
Foy
oh no
oh oh oh Lord in his hat is crazy I
think this is worse than being shot is
in front of everyone no poop in that hat
it's a
[Laughter]
lie oh God
oh
no I don't know why that I just walk if
I'm the other the third guy there I'm
walking away
that's
no that will never get out of my head
now I don't need to see that I can't see
that now I can't unsee
that listen
Foy
she's all yours you know I really do
care about you I don't know somewhere
along the line I guess I just forgot
that a relationship is a two-way street
yeah buddy that part I've been reminded
recently of what it's like to have
somebody care about me yeah buddy and I
like it so if you want to spend the rest
of your life with a full of
hair you know I just realized that last
joke might not have been clear I didn't
mean that she has a Harry I meant that
boy has a mustache so oh Aaron and I
understood it we got it he gets hair
it's okay in her we UND we got we good
goes down there we got it
Seth that was unnecessary appreciate you
SE yep right back at you
buddy
Anna go get your woman she's not there
hey do you do you think you guys are
going to have at some point I don't know
you do let us know cuz maybe we can make
it like you know
like we can all get in syn together
Edward we are not having sex sorry Ruth
let's coming
oh hate that for you
buddy now you need to char their own to
help you out with your confidence who's
the man who's hooked up with my wife to
be fair to Seth McFarland he had no idea
she was married he didn't she wouldn't
she wouldn't say him a thing about her
life I think he's a guy who doesn't give
a crap right shot an old guy for lying
to him twice clearly mph gives a crap
even one of my boys saw a man kissing my
wife last night rro I want to know who
it was oh man somebody's going to
get this is
mine
o
[Music]
ran
Reynolds
no why it's okay he's Deadpool he
regenerates he didn't even get a line at
noon tomorrow where I start killing more
people I forgot I think he had a cameo
in Ted too it's been a long time since I
saw the first Ted but I believe he had a
cameo in the first head there's a lot of
celebrities in this movie let me know in
the comment section if I'm wrong if he
had a cameo in the first head let him
know I I'm pretty sure he did it's been
like at least 10 years since I saw that
movie oh
Dam Mark Twain
yeah
who oh I just realized both Liam niss
and Y and McGregor are both in this Jin
and Obi-Wan yeah took me a second to
realize that you think I don't know when
you're
lying oh no no no no please don't don't
kill the dog please don't shoot the dog
don't shoot the doggy please come on
clinch oh you think I'm
joking who okay okay okay okay oh say it
was the must it's Neil Patrick Harris
it's Albert Stark Oh no just lie should
just said it was Neil Patrick
[Music]
Harris I've missed you baby no longer
the ride the lonely AR am man get d
of the woman he loves to
soo bones oh no and we have time to be
husband and wife the proper way hey
[__]
oh ass kill him oh [__] I can't leave
him like that kill him yeah why not just
take his gun and shoot him please put
put in his ass yay literally take his
gun and shoot him right now right just
kill him right you're just going to save
yourself so many so much problems later
I have no idea why you would not just
take his gun and shoot him right then
that's
dumb
Albert and you gave away Albert's name
so you really should have shot
him clinch is going to be looking for
you yeah not if you killed him seriously
I'm leaving uh I'm going to San
Francisco what I should have done a week
ago what about your D dad he's up on the
hill burying himself next to Mom damn
when did mom die I never meant to misle
okay you know what Anna don't even waste
my time you had a million opportunities
to tell me another million reference I
didn't tell you because I was trying to
protect you oh [__] you were looking
out for your own self-interest and
because I liked you I never thought I'd
meet someone like you Albert somebody
who hasn't killed people that's really
hard to find that's why women are always
going oh my God why are all the non-
murderers
taken we were married when I was nine
nine
what Jesus every girl that I ever fall
in love with ends up disappointing me
you love me oh you know what I'm over it
you you can go was I supposed to go oh
hi I'm Anna I've beening a killer since
I was oh he waited a year what a
gentleman is your name even Anna or is
it something terrible like
gwendaline I'm that same girl you fell
in love with I just didn't think I
deserved a good guy but you know what I
do I love
you uh it's a good thing you didn't
shoot him I'm sorry we keep harping on
it but it's just there's a trail out
back that leads out to the ridge go he's
going to kill Anna just go
Albert he always shoots on two so he
shoots on one you got to shoot on one or
zero or one and a half why didn't she
just kill him I don't know we'll
probably get crap for talking about that
in the comments but it still makes no
sense it doesn't make any sense
logically that's what you do well no uh
because Albert has to do it the the hero
I think that's why kill him cu the
script said she can't do it also because
Albert has
to he ain't here clinch how did he find
his residence do they find in the phone
book or they asked around I guess yeah
that that makes more sense St Tony I
know you're
here
who oh he's hiding amongst the Sheep yep
that's smart must be stinky in there a
sheep pretty sure we haven't seen West
study yet I got to imagine there's going
to be some Indians that help out in some
way sagot from Native Americans Andrew
sorry Native Americans I got
it it the red
rocket I don't need it I don't want it
in my face no thank you I got to imagine
that's what's going to happen because we
have not seen him at
[Music]
all
rad Stark
[Music]
ride it's actually pretty well
shot that's definitely Seth McFarland in
the far away shots 100% the wi shots yep
not a sun double
[Music]
whatsoever
keep riding don't
stop I would ride to the side next to
the train that was smart that' be
smart or do that or get in the train how
how the hell what the hell do we do now
how do you get the horse and you in
there let's not ask
questions I think this is when he sees
the Native Americans he comes back and
has them help him against clench when we
get out of this this I'm going to get
you some
horse sound good get you whatever you
want can get you a cow if you want one
of
those how the do you make a fire
yeah hello are you sure you want to do
this yes I'm absolutely sure wow I I
can't believe we're actually going to
have so just changed your mind with no
in town we could all by tomorrow that's
a good point okay okay all right I
thought they were playing
twister what are you in pain right now
you don't like it no I love
it yeah it's just it's just it looks
like a firecracker wrapped in roast
beef okay easy now sorry okay is that
right there yeah sure okay wrong okay I
get it it's pretty big right yeah you're
huge no I meant
you who is it Anna Anna whatever your
Sur name where can I come in sure I
don't even know each other met once have
they Haden together yet maybe they had a
deleted scene
maybe he's coming up the
stairs please don't shoot us on night
yeah you can't do that don't do that
don't be that guy
[Music]
oh I bet that smells
good Sagat
ah thank
you oh this is definitely giving me some
last of the Mohan
vibes
what he speaks our Native American
[Music]
language pays to be a
nerd
this is the way
drugs lose his
[Music]
[__] he's gonna freak the
out you weren't supposed to drink the
whole thing
yep
oh
no maybe you should have said toally
going to freak out and probably die
no holy
[__] is going to go
animated it's coming I see it I see it
oh when he came out of the womb it's a
boy Mr Stark all right well don't you
want to come hold the
baby
off now you put that under your pillow
and the Tooth Fairy will leave you a
penny yeah come on please welcome our
graduation speaker President Abraham
Lincoln whoa who's going to play
Lincoln who the hell is that
Gil four score and seven years ago oh
God RP good with GF yeah and I'm so
get rich I can have all the Licor I want
I got to show my dad this scene he loves
gilberg Godfrey hey Louise Louise check
out this cool bike I got hey you want to
go down to the L
[__]
oh oh my God
never what [__] not again that son of a
bit oh what oh wow
wa you're an idiot how can you be so
blind with eyes that big they're not
that
big oh The Lads and I have prepared
something special for
[Music]
you may hey a mustache a
mustache a
mustache okay come on
is he at the Pearly Gates looks like it
what the hell trippy we are the
guardians of the future is that Patrick
Stewart sounds like
it o the handle's going to bite him yep
come
on I know still you can call it out but
that doesn't mean I'm ready for it
you're right you're right you're
[Music]
right face your
fears Louis are Anna Anna Anna of
course a she's your
[Music]
future
oh K the burn in the balls that's so
dumb why the why they make me
laugh [__]
[Laughter]
hey good that's find out if your wee
boyfriend gives a [__] about you and
let's see if he's smart enough to shoot
me like you
didn't so he's been avoiding the fight
all film now he's ready to go up against
the craziest killer in the movie l b
come and take this
her don't be stupid Albert too late for
that he's already been stupid on two
you're pretty tough guy why don't you
prove it gunfight you and me right here
that's right get him on his
ego
oo take out your gun the gun with the
battle wounds on three the gun with the
high XP point it at
me he should on three on
one
[Laughter]
yeah
oh okayy look look look before you kill
me just grant me a few last words all
right make it
quick let Anna live this is not her
fault I kissed her she didn't kiss me I
mean she didn't tell me she was married
so it's a little bit her fault I guess
so okay
maybe just shoot her in the arm one more
thing um my grandparents were Arabic so
I'm required by Muslim is he bleeding
out in the arm death chant immediately
before dying this will only take a
moment poison
[Music]
bullet something's wrong with him poison
bullet oh that's Baltimore oh yeah
poison bullet he's tripping out jungle
light I'm far away from over you not
feeling well what's happening to me
there are A Million Ways to Die in the
West title and uh wild animals you know
like snakes you don't even have to get
bitten all you need is a little bit of
the Venom introduced into your
bloodstream and you're pretty much
screwed if you drain a certain amount of
Venom that's so cool you really only
need one shot now I knew my aim wasn't
good enough to hit you anywhere
important but if I caught you by
surprise very smart small amount of
Venom in an open wound is enough to kill
a man if he's
Albert he's dead is's
dead
oh that actually was a very smart plan
well done sheep boy hey sorry I killed
your husband oh God that was never going
to work out
anyway you're not really Arabic are you
no no no no oh thank God cuz I was like
a kill me I know right no God no we're
fine hey l
oh she wants him again hell no if you
want to talk about things I would like
that I can come back your place like
later tonight Louise I would but I
really got to go home and work on
myself throwing her words back at her
yeah damn dad's a lot of sheep holy how
you going to move anywhere way too many
sheep jeez Jesus and there's still on
the roof still one on the roof step
right up folks step right up this game
again take a gander at the shooting
gallery I'll take a shot oh God no
way I've never I've never seen this
movie but I know who that is hey I like
the way you die boy
you yeah that's like the perfect ending
I love
that very that's awesome hey you made a
Jango reference earlier too we were able
to call a couple cameos I guess that was
cool yeah I like that by the way if you
are listening to us on Apple or Spotify
if you would not mind giving us a rating
we would greatly appreciate it thank you
so much um I actually really enjoyed it
if we're going to go on the comparison
of like Ted or this I mean it's still
kind of fresh but I probably go the Ted
route but I still really enjoyed this um
there was a lot of runchy Comedy
obviously you're going to expect that in
a Seth McFarland thing I mean there was
a lot of the comedy I did enjoy there
was definitely some that fell flat um
but the thing I actually I mean we kind
of talked about during the reaction the
thing I really liked about it the most
was the character Arc that Seth Seth
McFarland went through you know like not
feeling good enough just uh confidence
and all that but I like that you know I
know it's a tropy thing we see in movies
like he needs a woman to help bring it
out of him but you know sometimes true
love does prevail and I really love that
about this film was uh or my favorite
thing rather about this film was uh the
relationship and the chemist between
Seth McFarland or rather Albert and anah
I thought they had such great
interactions I really appreciated those
scenes and when it actually did get
serious yes again there were some times
of levity that helped to you know break
the tension and all that but I really
appreciated it when when we were you
know in those serious romantic moments
um I thought they were really good
together and I actually really thought
that she was really helping him break
out of his shell like of just like so
locked in and focused on you know doing
everything to impress Louise if you will
and just like not feeling good enough in
life you know and I just I I mean that's
just a good life lesson you know um
about confidence and not feeling like
you're good enough and I just I loved
all those scenes and that was my
favorite part of the film um again I
like the comedy too for the most part
there were again some flat moments but
overall I I that was my favorite part
what about you I will say I I liked the
movie I don't think I liked it as much
as you but I had a good time watching it
and reacting to it I think the thing
that for me that I like when movies are
able
to balance comedy and drama obviously
this is clearly a comedy and this was
made by Seth McFarland who is the
creator of Family Guy and with that I
was not I would to say concerned but
part of me was thinking of like okay
what's this going to be like this guy
who's known for making TV a certain type
of way what's it going to be like when
he transitions over to a film and
watching that seeing that there was a
lot of scenes that stopped
just to have a bit like there was a lot
of like Family Guy type cutaways not
like cutaway to something else entirely
like it's like they referencing a thing
and then it cuss that thing but like
things within that scene they would cut
to and pause the momentum of it and also
there was a lot of scenes that ended
with a bit sometimes just to fill that
quot but I will say this did this movie
did make me laugh a lot uh there were
moments that there's a lot of moments
that were dumb but I think that we're
balanced well enough with the moments
that did work uh I will say that my
favorite part of the movie kind of what
Andrew touched on was the aspect of him
and Charlie theon's character and their
chemistry those were my favorite parts
of the movie because they had really
good chemistry I like the arc that she T
she brought him through with her kind of
teaching him confidence and to believe
in himself and the the nature of someone
giving themselves over to a relationship
when they're getting nothing in return
I'm like that's a very relatable thing
uh that people go through and watching
him go through his individual Arc as
well as the development of their
relationship was very rewarding very
satisfying I feel like okay this man is
really capable of giving us really good
dramatic genuine scenes and I would have
liked to have seen more of that Balan
with the comedy uh and not only balanced
with the comedy but I guess integrated
into the comedy because I feel like some
of the best movies that are comedies but
also have those things are ones that
really mesh that together very well
absolutely and I I fully agreee with
that uh also too on the flip side I
appreciated what Albert was bringing to
the table in terms of their relationship
because she's in such an abusive
relationship and obviously a forced
relationship forced to marry this guy
yeah at such a young age so you know it
was nice for her character to have like
meet such a guy who's not about violence
in any way and like just loves her for
who she is and I just thought they both
brought out the best in each other and I
do agree with you that I would have like
I mean well there was a lot of Comedy
that I did appreciate I did not feel it
was balanced enough for me to go oh my
God over the moon yes per Perfection
which it's not an easy thing to do you
know it's not like a um you know a thing
that's uh again that I'm heavily
criticizing the point of this is such an
easy uh fix it's tough like I thought he
did it well in in Ted uh but in this I
like that Back to the Future thing
sylvestri um but I feel like in this
film it what I mean cuz like you said
there were a couple bits at the end
where I'm like you could see it coming
but still it just didn't even though
this is again like a runchy type of
Comedy just with what we were going with
in some of these dramatic scenes it just
didn't well balance enough but having
said that I still found the film very
entertaining and enjoyable uh but and
also too I actually thought it was you
know the like it actually just seeing if
there's oh
oh what
the somebody brand me one of them white
women I need to watch that movie so I
can understand more fantastic oh know i'
I've always I've always heard how
amazing it is one of Quint n's best yeah
well I I've only seen a few of his uh
films so I definitely got to get on that
and many many other ones of his uh
filmography but um yeah know overall
though I I I mean I did appreciate and
enjoy it uh like you said I I would have
liked definitely if they could have
balanced a little more of the comedy and
those dramatic scenes but these two were
by far my favorite I actually really
even though he's a piece of crap I loved
Neil Patrick Harris's performance he was
fun A lot of fun he hysterical um which
again you're supposed to hate his
character so from that point of view he
he you know he got business done if you
will um but uh yeah no I mean overall
fun entertaining time it was a good
reaction I feel like I don't know if I'm
going to rewatch this movie um but you
know I had a fun time watching it I had
a fun time watching with you it had its
laughs uh I don't know if I'd watch it
again personally I know you guys don't
want us to give negative feedback about
movies sometimes but I got to be honest
in my opinion huh they W they want [__]
on this movie no I mean it it had it had
its moments like and and again I know
it's it's supposed to be a commedy it's
not supposed to be taken literally but
I'm sorry that one moment where and
again I get it he's supposed to get the
shot off of the poison which by the way
that was a well done scene by the way
with how he came up with the venomous
poison in the bullet I thought that was
really I loved it great but her having
like if Seth McFarland was going to have
her knock him out and do all that the
gun shouldn't have been present or
something I don't know it just that
annoyed me really badly with like she
could have easily killed him right there
like H yeah there there were a few
moments too many for me there was like
huh you get it you get the joke oh yeah
yeah I had to stop and go back and
explain like the hair thing like we we
got it we're smart you don't have to and
then Seth McFarland after he made a joke
he's like explaining the joke he like
did you get that one it's like bro like
it was fun good trust your audience we
understand yes also I thought it was
weird that and understand it was for the
point of comedy but how Seth McFarland's
character got to have his Arc in gaining
confidence but his friend just like is
oh just like doesn't change from start
to beginning from start to finish like
she just changes her she's not a version
anymore but all of a sudden she's like
okay I just changed my mind I was like I
wish we would have had done more with
that but overall if I had to rate it I'd
probably give it like a 6.57 give like a
six yeah I'll go 6.5 out of 10 go a
solid six I going to give give it a 5.5
but that feels a little harsh so I'll go
6.5 it made me laugh so I got to give it
a six six you know I'll give it a 6.7
just for that Doc Brown Cameo that I'm
probably going to be accused of having
seen or known about but I'll give it a
6.7.3 for docc Doc Brown J and you
McGregor and Ry Ryan Reynolds who had no
lines but it was nice to see him anyway
oh my God so many cameos I guess you
could also say Lois from Family Guy
right I mean there was just Lo from
Family Guy she was there's a lot of
great cameos you got to give that the
film that I mean Seth McFarland
definitely knows how to get on the phone
and say you're going to Cameo my you're
going to Cameo you too you too I mean
it's got a lot of connections got a lot
of connections but you guys do you guys
have a lot of connections did you guys
like this movie let us know in the
comments below uh we had a great time
watching it and hope to see you guys
pretty soon all right guys adios de
goose